elle manifeste avec toute la force du
désespoir
toutes ont survécu à l'enfer de
marioupol et sont bien décidés à tout
faire pour que leur père leur frère leur
fils leur mari soldat en sorte aussi
ce sont tous des frères d'armes là bas
ils font partie de notre famille dit
elle nous devons nous battre pour eux
pour essayer de les sauver en tant
qu'expression de
plus cela fait maintenant plus d'un mois
que des centaines de sodas jus craignant
sont coincés dans les banques heures et
une aile sully usine à d'obstacles de
marioupol
ils ont réussi à évacuer les civils mais
eux s'y trouvent toujours
bombardé sans relâche par l'armée russe
ils multiplient les appels à l'aide pour
tenter d'en sortir
nous savons que nous avons peu de
chances de survie ce nous sommes
capturer dit il il est donc impensable
de se rendre dans ces conditions
[Musique]
chaque jour de survie est donc une
petite victoire en soi un pied-de-nez à
l'ennemi qu'ils célèbrent à leur façon
mais les communications avec l'extérieur
sont difficiles cela fait maintenant un
mois et demi kolia n'a pas nouvelle de
son époux dima fraîchement mariés il
avait plein de projets et toute la vie
devant eux
mais la guerre est venue tout chambouler
depuis olia se repassent en boucle dans
sa tête leur dernier échange
je lui dis que je voulais vraiment avoir
des enfants à son retour dit elle beau
comme lui et intelligent comme moi et il
m'a dit qu'il le voulait aussi
ils se sont dit qu'ils s'aimaient qu'ils
se reverraient bientôt puis plus rien
alors comme les autres femmes des
combattants désole stahl olia ne rate
pas une occasion de se faire entendre
comme ici devant le palais présidentiel
l'action pour s'occuper l'esprit pour
s'accrocher à l'espoir pour s'empêcher
d'envisager le pire
nous voulons que notre président nous
explique pourquoi il sauve pas nous
sommes dit elle pourquoi une demande
palais d'autres pays pour les faire
sortir
un message visiblement entendu
nous continuons d'essayer de sauver nos
gens d'aso stade crises d'angine ski
précisant que des difficiles
négociations sont actuellement en cours
pour tenter de les évacuer des
négociations sous l'égide d'un flux en
médiateurs étrangers
mais pour les combattants d'azov talent
il est déjà minuit moins une beaucoup
d'entre eux sont lourdement blessé et
n'ont pas accès à des soins de santé
tous le savent leur temps est compté sur
ce mur se trouvent les photos des
soldats ils craignent un victimes de la
guerre avec la russie depuis 2014 quatre
mille cinq cents hommes et femmes morts
pour la patrie un lourd tribut et
pourtant le bilan actuel est bien plus
lourd car le mur n'a pas été mis à jour
depuis deux ans et de toute façon il n'y
aurait plus assez de place pour le faire
dc jean françois bélanger radio canada
qui vive